hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
edition of ask Evan today i'm answering
a question from one of our newsletter
readers garrick who is launching a
website and wanted my advice on what to
do so he wrote in saying i've been how
you're doing i'm getting ready to launch
our website it's a lot it has a lot of
different products on the site i would
like to send out and get my website to
stand out and invite people to keep
coming back i'd also like to write a bio
anything else you think I should do
thank you in advance Garrick so thanks
for the question Garrett a great
question one a lot of entrepreneurs are
thinking about as they create their
websites or try to revamp their websites
I'm going to give you a little bit of
advice so the first thing I would do is
try to make sure that people can quickly
understand what you do and the value in
it for them so if you look at people who
visit a website most of them will bounce
and very quickly so a lot of people will
land on the website and within 10
seconds they're gone and so you want to
quickly convey value to the reader so
they land on your homepage do they
understand what you do and how you can
help them so whatever the strongest
value proposition you can put out there
is that's what you want to have running
your homepage so quickly people quickly
get a sense of what is it you do if it's
for them and if it's intriguing enough
to make them want to keep reading so if
you look at your staff you probably
point a lot of people do bounce very
quickly early on and a lot of times it's
because people don't see value in it so
you got to got to hook people with
immediate value when it quickly land on
your website for us what we do if you
look at our home page we have the famous
entrepreneur quotes so we try to inspire
entrepreneurs motivate them that they
keep going and to run their business and
be successful and on our homepage the
first thing that you'll see is a big
quote from a famous entrepreneur with an
inspirational message and that usually
hooks people to want to read more scroll
explore the site learn about us so
whatever it is for your business you
want to have that quick hook we will can
quickly understand your website and you
know hopefully it's for them the next
thing I would do is try to tell your
story
a lot of times entrepreneurs hide behind
their products or services and it's
boring and the way you're going to stand
up for your competition is to quickly
have a store that people can relate to
right people would rather buy from
people then buy from a company and the
more passion and emotion you are about
what you do and and the more you show
that you care the more other people are
going to care but if you're really
deeply passionate about what you're
doing people will pick up on it like a
fever and they'll want to get involved
in it as well so I don't know what your
business is but you know why did you
start it what really excites you about
it what motivates they keep going every
day and whatever product or service you
created why is that so deeply ingrained
into you right so you want to tell your
story so have you know a picture of
yourself hopefully on the homepage that
people can click on and from there
there's your story there's maybe a video
introduction the more it personal you
can make it the greater chances people
will stick around on your website longer
and trust your message right if you have
a hopefully a nice smile you look like
an honest person and they deeply believe
in your story it's easy to tell when
somebody's be icing right when you read
a corporate bio or you see some videos
that are obviously scripted you can tell
that SBS is not authentic and people
tune out but if you're passionate what
you're doing and there's a message that
you have there and you're telling a
story in a way that you deeply believe
in it people will watch and they'll tie
into it and they'll want to be a part of
your company and given the option
between buying from you and buy from
somebody else they don't want to buy
from you because they feel like they
like you and they know it when they
trust you and they want to do business
with you so tell your story right don't
hide behind whatever corporate brand you
have you want to be able to tell your
story that was a big lesson learned for
me actually was when i started my
website was i hid behind the famous
entrepreneur information on our website
and then we have a lot of famous
entrepreneur stories Donald Trump Oprah
Winfrey Bill Gates how they got started
lessons you can learn from them and I
started getting people to write in to
say we want to learn your story like how
did you get started and what are you
doing now and we're interested in
learning more about
what you're up to and so I took that the
heart and started posting some
information and people scooped it up
they just wanted to learn more and and
for me it's being authentic it's what I
love doing helping entrepreneurs i
created this business to try to help
entrepreneurs grow their companies and
be successful and so it's just living
the brand a little bit and people tie
into that story so for yourself whatever
made you want to start this business and
the people that you're helping create
some content around telling that story
so you can hook people in so the first
one is you know create a really strong
value proposition that people can
quickly understand and tie into the
second part is tell your story in an
authentic way that quickly stands out
and really resonates with people and the
third thing I would say is if you want
people to keep coming back to your site
have some kind of way to tie them into a
newsletter so somebody may visit your
website I think it's great you look at
your story great look your products and
services and say great is something i
could use but maybe that ready to buy
now we're really going to go search
online for something else and they may
have loved what you do but people are
busy right we all have day to day lives
that are very busy keep us tied up and
they may forget to come back to you or
they may see how what was that website i
really liked it but i can't remember it
so you you're going to lose a lot of
those people so what i would recommend
doing is try to hook them on to your
website by having a newsletter you can
have some kind of bonus offer a free
download white paper something to entice
people to want to sign up with you and
you start creating a relationship with
people and that way when they are ready
to buy they already know you like you
trust you want to buy from you and
there's an easy way for them to remember
how to get in touch with you so what I
try to think about it is is as dating
before you get married right you're not
going to go up to some random girl in
the Syrian saying will you marry me you
know you have to start dating app to get
to know them you have to see if it's a
fit or not you have to see if you really
don't like them and love them or not and
so the same thing when people are buying
from your your business again depends
how much you know your products and
services cost but the more expensive it
is the more they want to know you and do
the research before they make a decision
so if you can get them signed up to
newsletter and then send them valuable
information on an ongoing basis and be
kind of the trusted expert reliable
source that people go to for whatever
your product or service is then when
they're ready to make a decision or when
their friends are ready to make a
decision you're going to be the person
that they turn to because you're seen as
that expert that they feel like they
know and again the more person you can
make it the better so example on my
newsletter if you sign up for I have an
introduction video so I'd say I want to
introduce myself to you when I made a
quick video talking about how i got
starting business and lessons that I've
learned just for people to quickly get a
sense of you know what I do and why I do
it and then I'll share information about
entrepreneurs obviously because that's
what I do but i'll share my top 10
favorite books for entrepreneurs my top
10 favorite quotes that inspire motivate
me my top 10 favorite videos that i've
watched that that i love watching to
again give me some motivation and so
i'll share this information it's it's
personal ties into my story but it's a
lot of value add and then people look
forward to getting the newsletter and
there's obviously a lot of great
information and newsletter as well but
you put those into an autoresponder
sequence so that every week they get
something really helpful to you know in
my case grow their business but in your
case whatever their products or services
that you're trying to sell whatever
problem you're trying to solve for them
you giving them helpful ongoing
information and you're building a
relationship by email that otherwise
would have been built so there's a lot
of people who watch these videos of me
and read my newsletter and they feel
like they know me and mentoring some
personal questions on here and I may not
know you guys but a lot of a lot of you
feel like you know me which is great so
be able to build a relationship with a
lot of people and that helps my business
that helps my website it helps it helps
me feel good because I feel like I'm
helping more people as well which is the
kind of the core purpose of what I do so
if you can't I people on to that
newsletter and give them a reason to
sign up and create that relationship
where you're you know giving them
valuable information on a regular basis
not spamming them but valuable
information an ongoing basis then again
when they're ready to buy when their
friends are go to the bar you're going
to be the go-to trusted expert that
they're going to want to buy from so
hopefully that helps
good luck with the website keep us
posted with how you're doing and if you
have other questions please let us know
for those of you watching if you liked
the video give it a thumbs up I love
seemed to come in and makes my day
always when I see thumbs up happening on
the videos and I'd also love to hear
what you have to think if you have a
comment about this video if you liked it
you didn't like it or you have a
suggestion as well feel free to leave it
below and if you have a question for
your own business that I can answer for
you I'd love to be able to try to do it
I always read those comments so feel
free to leave it in the section below
and thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you